[Music]
there was just as much action behind the
scenes as on screen with camera people
running around and intense visual
effects being produced live
the glass stone's ending definitely
caught us off guard but the process to
capture the way it surprised kyon sebiak
and sang wu was an extensive one
filming the actors only had a small
amount of glass explode near them the
slow-motion feeling really comes through
in how the actors perform
after capturing shots of the trio each
got to do their close-up work with
singles as well
it may be a short moment but plenty of
hours were put into capturing every
nuance and angle
when time came for the big visual of the
glass stepping stones we see exploding
the team didn't resort to cgi for the
shards of glass
except for the ones that appeared to
harm the players and fly towards the
camera they actually went ahead and
created the whole sequence in studio
these practical effects look unreal on
the set it's no surprise it translates
to such a powerful and stunning visual
in the episode
hello players let me welcome you all to
the fifth game
the cast of squid game dove right in
when playing glass stepping stones and
definitely didn't have it easy since for
many it was actually terrifying to film
while cgi came into play in terms of
establishing the setting and just how
high in the air the players were much of
the carnival-like set was fully built
even the glass fortunately no one
actually went through shattering glass
instead landing on a board supported by
a crew to allow the actor to fall safely
[Music]
in the show the set that red light green
light takes place on already seems
awfully crowded with the nearly 500
players but on the set there were even
more folks making it a pretty chaotic
yet well-organized space we would have
thought cgi was used to add the bodies
of those who lost during the game
especially the piles of people at the
doors but the actors all actually stayed
wherever they were when they lost the
game which couldn't have been very
comfortable when it came to filming
close-ups multiple cameras were used to
capture the performances and the filming
crew was often running along with the
players the added detail of using a red
marker to signal when a person took a
shot is evident of just how thorough and
meticulous the team was no one could get
away with cheating during the game
either if one person moved out of time
we're looking at you sang wu
then everyone had to start over
today's game is
tug of war
the performers did not have it easy
playing the often physically demanding
games when filming the series since they
really were going through the struggle
depicted on screen the sweat effort and
even chained handcuffs securing them to
the rope were real
there definitely couldn't be much
movement between takes since everyone
was literally tied up together with a
scene like this there isn't really any
other way to do it than at 100 percent
maybe one of the most terrifying gasp
worthy moments in the show is seeing
guillen hanging between safety and the
end of the game for his whole team the
tension is real even though the platform
they were on was just a meter and a half
off the ground while swinging on a rope
is usually pretty fun this collective
rope swing down tells a very different
story and shows just how far the actors
and production went to bring the best
footage to the screen
my god i can't believe how cool that was
the moment after the most intense tug of
war we've ever seen is so still but we
can see just how exhausted each and
every actor is having just struggled and
fought for their lives literally this
shot is definitely needed as a moment of
pause after the insane game just played
resulting in so many lives lost this is
also a bit of a moment of reckoning this
was hard but whatever was coming next
would only be harder and they knew it
you know what i really thought we were
going to die out there
for the final face-off the sound stage
was a lot emptier with just gyon and
seng-wu competing but there were many
camera people often filming using
handheld video cameras to capture all
the frantic action not only that their
crew made it rain making the whole scene
just as dramatic as the gruesome fight
we see in the final cut as filming went
on the two actors only got more
disheveled with rain soaking through and
blood effects added throughout the
battle in order to get all the footage
they needed the actors had to be on
point at every moment
i won't let you leave here with that
money
the honeycomb scenes looked pretty
similar on set as they did in the show
with the exception of the childlike
drawn wallpaper the rest of the set was
filled with giant playground equipment
and the smell of freshly made dalgona
the korean honeycomb sweet luckily the
actors didn't have to listen to the
actual loud noise each time a bullet was
fired as someone on set was in charge of
giving a shout to indicate the moment
instead so the performers had a solid
unified cue to react to
behind the scenes we get a glimpse of
just how hands-on the director was when
it came time to shoot
surprisingly the cavernous cool space
where we see the confrontation between
the police officer and a team member of
the squid game is real the opening on
the top of the cave and the murky pool
made the ideal setting no doubt the
actors felt totally immersed in the
story shooting these scenes were pretty
simple all they needed were a couple of
cameras the right costumes and the
actors chilling performances
do you want to die
the glimpses we get of the players lives
before the game offers such a colorful
backstory especially when we see them
with their families
each of these scenes were shot quite
intimately and simply focusing on the
narrative and what these relationships
meant to the player which translated to
the screen beautifully it's also one of
the only times we get to see a typical
everyday aesthetic making the stark
contrast between the real world and the
squid game world even more apparent so
which color do you want to play as
how could we forget the original squid
game filming this scene may have been
one of the simplest setups using an
existing playground space it only adds
to the realism of the show and offers a
great reminder of where the players
started as innocent children playing
games for fun instead of their lives
at that moment
i felt as if i owned the entire world
hanging out in the dorms between games
certainly wasn't any less stressful than
the games themselves
the bare bones set with the cool
industrial edge does the trick and the
feeling of the daunting space comes
through the screen what we saw in the
show was almost exactly what was
happening on set with all the added
cameras and crew people of course
we can't fall asleep tonight okay who
knows what someone else may try
many moments in the marbles game bring
intense connection and emotion the way
they shot these scenes was a pretty
stark difference from so many of the
large and intense games the fact that
the actors were in a small space
together with just a few crew members
around really helps the intimacy come
through and offers us the chance to get
up close and personal with these
characters and the short but meaningful
relationship they have playing marbles
we'll go around this town and take all
the marbles
one of the reasons the marbles game is
so effective is because of just how well
the setting transports us to the alleys
of a small village
it makes sense that this is the set the
team spent the most time building every
detail down to the stunning backdrops
moves us
it's no surprise they got the
performances they did the authenticity
of this world is remarkable
my wife and i have this one here
the use of practical effects cgi and
incredible actors really went a long way
in making the production so high caliber
fortunately the actors didn't really
have to go head to head during tug of
war since there was a machine pulling
against whichever team was being filmed
which squid game would you try